nobody wants to see a small class of
dick flapping around
that [ __ ]
put that [ __ ] away what are we hearing
away or something
it's yeah i don't have yeah no shade no
shade yeah but nobody wants to see that
little
do you ever i have a question
like do you tuck your penis i'm tucked
right now wow
can you explain tucking i've actually
been curious oh my god you need to show
you guys
yes
okay yeah how do you talk okay
if i
i don't know how i could give you a
visual
it's like obviously a no you got a penis
right yes yes
jesus these this is these are the balls
you got some balls hanging on the side
right this is the penis yeah
these
there's a y'all are gonna grow y'all are
gonna vomit
there's a pocket
up there
you know what i'm saying there's a
pocket
there's a pocket guy
you know like before you hit puberty
your balls are somewhere they're not up
there yeah and then they drop so there's
a pocket up there where you can pop them
and they stay no so you pop those babies
up there
stay there and then you bring it all
back oh you pulled it and what happened
yeah what happens if you get erect
like what happens you get a kiss on the
cheek it just comes
too long of eye contact good luck um
itself i mean it depends it depends
there are different methods too because
i'm just i'm lucky where i live in the
age now that there is underwear
that you could just pop on and just tuck
and it's perfect
even even two years
it's like it's like a band and your ass
is out and it's just like that that baby
that's a joke strap yeah
don't act like you haven't seen that
part in scary movies
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah so it just all goes back but there
are different methods so i i just wear
underwear but there are a lot of girls
and there are a lot of drag queens too
who tuck and like full-on wear tape and
keep it back yeah
it's intense
it's intense and it is painful it is
painful i do have scars because you know
i mean depending scholars
yeah from yeah well from taping and
doing stuff but also to
obviously your skin's being pulled
there is a point
um there is a point in time where
obviously it starts like this
there will be
whether it's tape or it's underwear
there's like skin you know that will pop
out that will not be in the tuck and if
you're sitting in a bad situation it
like i've had like my the skin will
pinch
and it's like a pain that you
can't imagine all trans girls who are
who may be watching this will know the
the amount of pain
the kind of pain
that it takes to untuck your penis
um
what do you call a period
a genus a sheenus a sheenus yes like a
penis yes
i don't actually call it that i just
said it right now oh
did you hear derek say that's y'all's
childbirth
she was just describing the pain because
you guys are women so everything is
relatable childbirth has nothing on
untucky
i'm kidding
you